I was so motivated to be the best I
could be that it wasn't I wasn't
motivated to be the starter I wasn't
motivated to win the Super Bowl I just
was motivated to give my best do the
best with the opportunity I got and to
never let my teammates down those were
my motivations so this is at the
beginning you were saying it's beginning
and throughout this is why people would
say after a second Super Bowl that we
won in the third Super Bowl that we won
and a fourth Superboy we won in 2014
against Seattle and if this Super Bowl
against Atlanta in 2016 and a 6-1
against the Rams in 2018 and then they
go to Tampa it was the same motivation
money didn't motivate me Fame didn't
motivate me I didn't give it about any
of it I always took less money because I
wanted a good team around me I I didn't
care about going to all these different
places and doing those things I just
wanted to to be my best I wanted to go
out there and the team believed in me I
didn't want to let him down